[Music]
joshua bassett
just released his new single lie lie lie
and now some fans think it's about
olivia rodrigo that's pretty crazy
just to get you up to speed last week
olivia dropped her new track
driver's license
[Music]
some fans were quick to point out the
lyrics appeared to be about her high
school musical the musical the series
co-star and rumored ex joshua
leaving her for his alleged new boo
sabrina carpenter
and you're probably with that blonde
girl
who always made me doubt
she's so much older than me she's
everything i'm insecure
about yet now fans think lie lie lie
is his response to all that here's why
in the lyrics josh calls out someone for
lying about him
so they told me all the things that you
said
running all over my name
[Music]
yeah so there's that and it didn't stop
there
so you're telling them it's all my fault
[Music]
then there's the fact that a few of the
car visuals in josh's video
totally match olivia's like this moment
where they both lay on the car
and this whole dramatically lit purple
situation
but on wednesday the 20 year old singer
hit up instagram to explain the true
meaning behind the song
revealing that he wrote it after a
friend had been lying about him behind
his back
for a long time quote it always sucks to
hear that someone you thought you could
trust would throw you under the bus
when it benefits them it happens to all
of us and i think
all you can do is seek out people who
build you up
a friend huh i think one of the things
that i've really learned from
olivia is the um the storytelling aspect
of songwriting and i think that i
you know i'm more of like a this is how
i feel in this moment and she really
does a job of like
telling a story and putting you in that
time and place and i think that
that's been super um inspiring to me and
has definitely influenced
my music but i definitely think that we
we kind of we
uh you know we grow from each other so
while the lyrics sound like they could
be a response to seventeen-year-old
olivia's song
it's important to note josh actually
performed a demo of lily lie
on instagram back in november 2019
before their rumored 2020 split
[Music]
and while josh hasn't commented on the
speculation he
did hit up instagram on thursday to
reveal that he spent the day
in the emergency room after feeling
quote the worst pain of my life
hey josh you got this
in the caption he assured his fans that
the hospitalization was
not covid19 related writing welp
not the first place i assumed i'd be on
my li li lie release date
the er he added that he had his first
surgery on thursday night
and said gonna rest at the hospital and
the doctors will see what they see
in the morning